pineda last year
missed the beginning part of the season
but was real good down the stretch for
the twins and
continued that in his first start in
milwaukee did a nice job and didn't give
up a run mitch haniger leads off for the
mariners chopper to simmons
one down one away and the batter is ty
france
calm third strike
went up and away look at the target
i mean as a catcher that's you dream
about catching guys like this
right center field buxton dodger runs
and makes a catch didn't have to die
pineda throwing strikes
or you say this will be his second start
of the year really pissed well in his
first outing last year nine starts two
and four five one seven era
breaking balls here this one's sky
who's going to take charge hanniger does
one else one out and target field brings
up kyle with garlic
struck him out luis holds on two down
cruz three homers seven knocked in so
far on this young season
practiced bad
could have died a hero
aboard with a two out single two out one
on two pitch
that's tag
hagerty
cruz will hold it second
two out two on mitch garver
playable for hanniger kaguchi is going
to get out of it second inning jose
marmaleo's to lay things off for the
mariners no attack early
fastball gets him
but when you're able to do that just
like that you go 0102 if he's 2-0 he
doesn't chase that pitch up out of the
zone right there
chopper to third or rise charges fires
on the run
a little stretch by suno two down a good
play by luis udais turned 24 yesterday
pineda razor sharp again a pair of one
two three innings three strikeouts and
just 26 pitches thrown
one two pitch
and torrence holds on there again
two strikeouts for kikuchi went away
here in the second and his best fastball
at 97 miles an hour one or two here to
snow
straight away
and trammell
is right there for out number two
three two pitch swing and a miss struck
him out into the second inning
taylor tremell that's big moments in
spring training gotta get this
major league portion of his career going
he leans into this one right field
indeed maybe this is a moment former's
first home run and yes it is his first
big league home run taylor tremell and
the mariners have a one-nothing lead
well this is center cut for him right in
the middle of the plate
well done congratulations to him so one
out jp crawford
will pop up and
arise tracking this one easier play
two down pineda will face mitch hanniger
here the pitch
swung on it slug to left field this is
hammered this has got a chance it's
gonna go
out of here upper deck mitch henniger
into the second level
turns on it for the second home run of
the inning
just
blasts it to left field and the mariners
have a two nothing lead for mitch his
second long ball of the season
there's kyle garlic struck out his first
time on there's a liner into left field
and dartmouth with a one-on-one single
here comes nelson cruz
driven hard to right field crews going
back
tie game he did it again
a bullet to right field and it's two
apiece
nelson crews right on cue i mean
compared to so many other power hitters
across the game
he can let that ball travel let it get
so deep
and hit opposite field home runs it
really just looked like he's trying to
hit the ball over the second baseman's
head it's just so effortless but he's so
strong
breaks up the right fielder max kepler
popped it
up jp
type ball game nelly did it to the
fourth
pinata at the belt and the pitch sort of
missed
chased it outside
and michael picks up strikeout
number four
here's shortstop angelson simmons he
walked in the second
there's a ground ball
there's one and there's two right on
time two down
taylor trammell despite the cold had a
very memorable moment in his last at bat
hitting his first big league home run
and pineda clips the inside corner one
away
brings up sam hagerty
sam looking to bust out he's out of the
gate over 13. up the middle there it is
first hit of the season for sam
hanager homer in his first time her
second time up after
rounding
to the shortstop here is polanco firing
across
and pineda with five strong innings
again
and the left-hander's 3-2 on the way to
garlic swing and a miss and a knee-high
fastball for strike three so two outs
for the twins here in the bottom of the
fifth inning that is strikeout number
five for usa kikuchi brings up nelly
cruz two for two singing on a line drive
homer on right field
not gonna get that one back and standing
the ballpark tramell is there friends
call out on strikes his first time up
here to warning track fly ball to right
center third breaking ball gets struck
three on the way
popped up short left field
racing in is garland
and he's there for the catch a one two
three six
for big mike
trying to elevate a fastball right here
liner and he hit it too hard a bullet to
hannigar went away mitch garver fly to
right and to strike him
breaking ball and a beauty got him
strikeout looking two down in the sixth
strikeout number six for kikuchi michael
pena six innings four hits couple of
runs they were two solo shots michael
didn't walk anybody had six strikeouts
tyler duffy is on for the fourth time
tapper to third backhanded by that eyes
down the day is done for you
very nice outing for usa casey sadler
will take over for the mariners here in
the seventh
swinging a miss nice shot by casey
sadler we go to the eighth still tied at
two so two outs the go ahead run is
still on its second and jp crawford
that'll bring up kyle seeger
center field buxton can't get it
jp coming around third and he's gonna
score in the mariners have a 3-2 lead
on an eighth inning
two out two-strike base hit
by kyle seeger
malejos over three today
carver hangs on to strike three but the
mariners get a couple of hits around a
stolen base and they've taken a 3-2 lead
garlic cruz and buxton coming up in the
eighth inning
broke his bat looper going out might be
trouble dylan nice play
well done good line on it and reached up
didn't make the play
you see him turn right away
catches it and then slams into the
ground holds on to it good job keeping
that glove up squeeze it tight yeah
quick delivery super mow on the catch
right on the end of the glove too still
able to hold on to it full count to
garver
tap her to third double play grounder
and they'll only get the one
seeger looked at second base and then
realized who was running kepler with two
runners in scoring position and the
twins down a run
that gets away cave is coming home
to tie the game
and now kepler will take a free pass to
fill first base and they'll hope to get
sono out two and two
track three call
3-3 ball game we go to the ninth two
down we'll bring up polanco
in there again ground ball marmot takes
it to the back taylor tremell who made
the last out of the ninth inning will be
at second base as we go to extra innings
bishop bleeds off
there we go beautiful bunt
braden bishop can run he held on
face hit they got henniger one out
runner at third infield still in close
that's going to get the job done
sliding catch
scoring is tremel and the mariners have
the lead at 4-3 mitch haninger second
rbi today
and the mariners one out away from an
extra inning victory in minnesota but
they have to go through one of the
hottest hitters in baseball to do it
jp time game over mariners win it 4-3
and 10.
nice job a lot of good things in this
ball game today